jared good to see you man how are you
nice nice to see you too i'm good man
it's cool to be able to speak here at
the audi innovation series
with your you know wealth of experience
and knowledge what do you hope to impart
on the audience on the people watching
and listening
i don't really i don't know that's an
interesting question i i i
i'm always happy to share my experience
uh being a creative person
and talk about
uh fear and failure which seem to be a
pretty consistent thing when you're uh
maybe it's just consistent fear of a
human being but
um certainly when you take a a creative
path in life it's filled with a lot of
a lot of challenges it's on specific
challenges and
you know those are the things that uh
you know i found in my life
um you know have taught me probably the
most
so i mean anyone that's followed
what you do that's in the public eye in
your music and in your acting they know
that you
take those risks and those challenges
and is the idea that
you're sort of teetering on the edge of
um
something great or maybe something
tragic is that part of what
drives you or you is it always just
looking forward to something that
is a challenge for you i think there's a
little bit of both um
i think it's a little bit of both it's
just the old cliche without great risk
there isn't great reward
and um i certainly found that to be true
in my life i like to
uh
i think i just like to push myself to a
place that i haven't been before i like
to learn new things i like that
that the kind of surprise and delight
of new experiences
climbing new mountains you know you know
with your love for fashion
how what does it feel like for you to be
able to get into
i approach the story from this angle you
know we've we've seen you
in gucci plenty of times and now you're
playing gucci as well yeah yeah it's
it's it's uh it's a kind of a
nice coincidence they actually the gucci
brand and the gucci film
um they're supportive
of one another but they're not involved
um
uh really uh so the fact that i was
working working with gucci before had
nothing to do with being
cast in the film um but it was fun for
all and fun for me to be involved with
both
and and yes i've worked with gucci for
many years and they're just a great
group of people the brand
uh and um i've really close friendships
there and it's just been
it's always fun to work with really
creative people that are great at what
they do
and uh it's fun to witness that it's fun
to be a part of that it's fun to be a
part of the gucci family
and uh and then working on the gucci
film was fascinating i actually never
even knew the history of gucci
i didn't know how much you know
drama and how much infighting there
was i didn't know um what a
wild story uh uh the the the house of
gucci was
i played paolo gucci and it was a
complete transformation
um which i enjoyed a lot it was about
five hours of prosthetics every morning
and um really just a journey to to uh
bring this character to life amazing now
finally
before we go uh you're celebrating a big
birthday this year
and we have to be you know hopeful about
the way the world is changing coming up
to
your big birthday so do you have any
plans in place
i'm not big on birthdays um because my
birthday i think one of the reasons
is i mean i don't mind birthdays i don't
have a problem with them
but i think one of the the the reasons
is my birthday is the day after
christmas so it's usually like
a pretty quiet uh day which i don't mind
um
but i'm not so big on uh on
on birthdays or anniversaries
uh which sounds really bad
but i guess i celebrate you know i i
tend to find a lot of
joy in the small things you know i'm a
rock climber and you know
it's not about i've never climbed any
mountain or cliff obsessed with just
getting to the top
um i i'm more interested in
the experience and what that experience
is like because i've climbed routes
uh on cliffs and gotten at the top and
you know i did i've enjoyed some more
than others
um so it's really about the line it's
about the path it's about the journey
it's uh uh yeah nothing not the
destination
as they say as as far as models go i i
think that one's one of the best for
sure
sir thank you so much for your time
really great talking to you all the best
my pleasure
you